you're the king of the Met Gala the king
of camp you brought this to the masses
what does this mean - for you to be here
and tell me about this love what's a
wonderful night it's a great chance to
get to see everybody and wear some wild
clothes this is right up my alley
I love everything about this and of
course Aldi who does my gowns did this
outfit and you know we've been working
together for over 25 years so this this
event was made for Saul Dee and I yes
tell me about camp educate me a little
about what this means
well we're it's the people who can see
who can break the fourth wall who can
see beyond the facade of life and that's
really where life begins when you can
see it as a construct and then have fun
with it and laugh at it crazy is it that
Kim kardashian-west is on one side of
you Gwyneth Paltrow is right behind it's
a brilliant night all the stars are here
Kim Kardashian Tom Ford
Gwyneth Paltrow everyone is here and
it's such a great event thinks gonna win
drag race you know every year we have
dragons
every year we have drag race and there's
always one winner
Amy okay I'm voting for panchi okay
you
[Music]